you say in literature there are four
basic voices or tonalities
well five if you count
your own voice your natural
speaking voice as a writer so the other
four
there's only four other tonalities in
all of western
literature and um
i have a standing offer to any of my
students
if they can comb any piece of writing
from homer to the present and find
a page or a paragraph or even one
sentence
that's not one of those four then i will
give them
and and i have a one of those play money
says a billion dollars and i hold up the
billion dollar bill and i go if you can
find a sentence it's not one of those
four
and i hold up the billion dollar bill
say i'll give you a billion dollars
and so far no one has collected it so
there's only four
basic styles or tones
or voices depending on how you want to
look at it in all of western literature
beside writing in your own
your own tone and then there's the other
four
and those other four are uh tommy billy
sarah and becky oh okay oh i know becky
yeah
um well one of them is what i
call straight talk all the the the names
i use
come from a poem by another writer so
nikki giovanni has a poem called
straight talk
so i use that in other words and these
would all be the writing in your own
voice
i cover that uh how to get the voice
deep and all that in my uh
my first book on method writing called
method writing
uh and then uh the four voices
that you just asked me about uh i cover
in my second book
um it's called advanced method writing
and at the bottom it says
the art of tonal dynamics so it's how to
take these four
tones and use them the way uh
a composer of music would use different
kinds of
musical percussion effects and you know
whatever because tones change in music
very deep and then suddenly it becomes
light and so forth so the four
tones that i have i have names for him
straight talk means you're not in the
deep voice
you're very chit chatting everything is
boy you won't believe what happened last
night i mean there i am standing on the
corner and would you believe it
a guy comes up and he's got a cigarette
in his nose and i thought you know
very chit chatty the opposite of the
deep voice
the second voice is uh that writerly
poetic
style that a lot of writers use and that
a lot of writers think you're supposed
to write like that
where you give metaphors and similes and
fancy description and all that kind of
stuff and on a scale of 1 to 10 you
could do it in a subtle way or you could
do it in a very extreme way
so for instance if you read william
faulkner
or marcel proust these are writers who
write in a very ornate style
almost out of ten but then there are
other writers who use
a little bit of style but they're only
at a one or a two but it's all
not writing in your natural voice it's a
heightened style
then the third voice is the oldest
technique in all of
writing it's where you repeat it goes to
the bible
you know it goes all the way back to the
bible where you
you repeat things three times four times
five times
so a lot of your great politicians or
preachers
will use this voice i have a dream
that one day blah blah blah blah blah i
have a dream that one day blah blah blah
blah blah
i have a dream that one day blah blah
blah nobody remembers
the blah blah blah but everybody
remembers
the i have a dream speech because by
repeating it
he makes that a kind of drum beat a
rhythmic
pulse so that is the most ancient form
of writing
that was how people remembered because
people couldn't read so even if someone
wrote something they would they would
perform it
the repetition of phrases uh it was the
best of times it was the worst of times
from charles dickens or the bible
there's a time to
to be born and a time to die a time to
plant and the time to sow
a time to buy in a time you know the
repetition
creates a way to remember because
people couldn't read so you had to know
to remember so that device
that repetition is a technique that can
be used in more ways than you realize so
when i teach it first people have to
know how to do it
you know it's just how to do it then you
learn
many different ways you can use it there
can be subsets of the repetition
with different repetitions abraham
lincoln's gettysburg address
see these people around that time they
studied
what was called the the greek and latin
revival
and that was one of the things you
studied if you went into politics or
into religious preaching was the
repetition
you studied that so lincoln's gettysburg
address comes directly from that
where you you repeat something he talks
about
in the gettysburg address we've come
here to
dedicate a portion of this field as a
final
resting place of those who here gave
their lives that
you know we may live blah blah blah and
then he goes but in a larger sense
we cannot dedicate we cannot consecrate
we cannot hallow this ground so we
cannot we cannot we cannot
237 words i think is the gettysburg
address
if you go through it you will find five
or six places
where lincoln repeats something like a
mantra
three four sometimes five times in a row
and he does it at the very end
at the very end that this nation
shall have a new birth of freedom and
something something what is it do you
remember how he ends his speech
of the people by the people
for the people so that's a repetition
that is a technique that he learned
in in his studies so that's the third
voice
then the fourth one is actually not a
it's where you use language in a
non-communicative way
um where you're writing almost stream of
consciousness or
or absurd images or
maybe you've got someone who's got
alzheimer's or someone is drunk
but it's language that is not used in a
normal linear way and poets and writers
have been doing that
for at least over a hundred years
started in france with arthur rambo and
baudelaire and and then the russian
futurists were doing it
they created the thing called zom poetry
that didn't make sense and
so forth so any writing that is kind of
like modern art where you have cubism
or abstract painting or abstract
expressionism
where you're just seeing a lot of crap
on the canvas well what would be the
analogy of that with words
well it would be words and sentences
that don't make any sense in other words
i did a whole book of what i and i
called it absence of field
because there's no logical feel
to it it's all disconnected on the page
so i kind of took that idea and i have a
book called lucky finds
in which i put it all on card so when
you
when you got my book um oh i'm back
um it's called lucky finds so but
actually it's not a book
it's a bunch of cards and if you
and when i teach in in the classroom
with kids
i lay all this out on the floor and the
kids
absolutely love it you know i just
spread all the cards out on the
floor and they're um
you know they're just i mean things are
this way in that way
and i hand drew those letters that you
see there
what is that there's another one there's
another one yeah
a little bit i'm just curious what what
are some of like if you chose one
they're different letters so yeah
they're hand drawn
i draw them and sometimes the writing is
upside down and sideways
i'll do a different font but each piece
is kind of a
um it hangs together in a way but it's
up to the reader to figure it out
something like that but when i show this
to kids in school
we spread all the cards out on the floor
and then they make their own and they
gets
they just love it they they absolutely
love it
see on this one you got to read it this
way then you got to turn it upside down
and read it that way
oh here's one where i just have a lot of
negative space
and it just says carbon cycle
illustrious and then there's those two
letters
so you know i play with the forms
so it's not just like you're reading a
story or a poem it's all
broken up there
anyway there's 52 of them and
it's called lucky fines because it's
like you come across something
on the pavement and you pick it up and
go oh a quarter
a lucky find for a new writer
should they try these different
tonalities or personalities or just stay
in the beginning with their authentic
voice and then once they
have mastered that then venture out to
these other sort of areas
well you know as i said i'm kind of an
old athlete and
i learned boxing and swimming and
football and
basketball and how to play golf
i always noticed that when you're being
taught
you're being taught from the ground up
uh
you're being taught basic movements and
then you build on that
for instance when i was boxing
i spent a long time not being allowed to
throw punches
everything had to be footwork and i
thought come on when do i get to punch
somebody
but when you learn footwork you discover
that
a punch will have as much strength
not as your power here but in your legs
and if you are balanced when you throw a
punch
and if you are transferring the energy
from the legs
to the body you get more power
so everything depends on the legs and
and the stance
same with tennis when you're playing
tennis if
if your feet are too close together or
too far apart
you don't have as much balance or power
so one of the things you learn playing
tennis is you learn to
run to where the ball is and then plant
your feet
correctly before you swing
because if your feet are planted
correctly then the swing
you know if you learn how to do the
swing that would be the next thing
but you foundation is very important so
in my first class in method writing it's
all about the voice
how to manipulate the natural voice and
yeah you practice we we have
exercises that you do from week to week
and
we work on that then when you go to my
advanced class
now we work on the four voices and again
you're practicing
and at some point we have an exercise
where you get a pair of dice
and you throw the dice and each number
corresponds to
one of the concepts you've learned up to
this point
so if a number two comes up and let's
say it's
the the fancy schmancy voice
you've got to write four lines of fancy
schmancy
then you roll the dice again oh six
comes up what is that
oh that's uh straight talk well hey one
you won't believe what happened but
it's all the same piece it's a it's all
a coherent
idea or story but you're switching
every four lines and so everybody thinks
oh it's not going to make any sense
but it ends up making perfect sense
because you're changing tonalities
and it's the change of tonalities that
makes for drama
more than just the drama in the story
i don't know if you fully get that the
story
isn't where the drama is the drama is in
the tonalities that you switch
and great composers when they write they
don't just write the same note
100 times they're changing uh when when
beethoven took my class
early on uh he had written a symphony
and he brought it in
and the opening of the symphony went
this way
it's a little boring you're doing
nothing with the deep voice why don't
you do like the straight talk voice you
know where you
you get high like that and he said oh
well i got to try that
i better do that next week and then he
comes in next week
and he did the deep voice but then he
switched
to that very light voice so now when you
listen to the fifth symphony it goes
[Music]
very good ludwig you're getting the idea
of
tonal dynamics you want to switch those
tones
so when they do that dice thing it
surprises a lot of them they go wow that
really worked
the piece made sense those changes in
tone
didn't give the reed a whiplash it just
felt like
good writing and good writing is
tonal dynamics and one of the reasons
why a lot of people's stories are boring
is because the voice is the same
all the way through
you